it was pretty typical
a typical process it just was on a much
grander scale you know it was something
that went over seven months I did sort
of I think I did seven or eight
different auditions I flew out to
Atlanta multiple times for a different
screen tests and then when I was going
for my last audition
I was driving I was very nervous and I
had this driver a lovely guy but a
little bit too honest and uh
he's sort of sitting there in the car
and he's chatting to me chatting to me
chatting to me and I'm you know I'm a
polite person but I also want to be like
mate please shut up
and uh he's looking at me in the mirror
and he's doing that thing he's like yeah
sort of sitting there really awkward
he's looking at me he's looking at me he
goes you know what kid I think you're
going to get it I'm not really why and I
was excited to hear that and he goes you
know what I think you're going to get it
because the kid that I just drove there
he is so good looking
that's exactly the confidence boost I
need and then I like you know I've got
the part I was lucky enough I saw him a
few months later when I was shooting the
film and he goes I told you I was like
what did you tell me that I was going to
get the part or that was ugly
you should have had what he said to the
next guy yeah
[Music]